les liaisons dangereuses de choderlos de
laclos à la manière anglo american le
film sort demain en france
voilà monsieur bonsoir c'est un record
bien de chez nous qui est en jeu un
triste record celui de la consommation
d'alcool
un homme de 49 ans automobilistes bien
sûr a été contrôlé en fin de semaine
dernière dans la marne résultats 5,89
gramme par litre de sang
vous avez bien entendu 5,89 g
comment est ce possible patrick esther
pour un homme de corpulence normale
moyenne comme moi c'est à dire entre 60
et 70 kg avoir 5 g 89 d'alcool dans le
sang
cela signifie ceci avoir bu six
bouteilles de 75 centilitres de 20 c'est
à dire une cinquantaine de verre
pourtant paradoxalement c'est fort taux
d'alcoolémie restent marginaux si l'on
considère qu'en permanence 3 % des
conducteurs ont plus de zéro g 80
d'alcool dans le sang
l'année dernière 3800 personnes sont
mortes sur les routes de france du fait
de l'alcool avec zéro g 80 d'alcool dans
le sang
on est euphorique le risque est
multiplié par 10 avec 2 grammes on voit
double et cette fois le risque est
multiplié par 80 alors que dire pour
ceux qui ont 5 g 89 d'alcool dans le
sang
willy ronis l'histoire le record n'est
même pas battu il est toujours détenu
par une femme mère de famille contrôler
il ya un an dans le loir-et-cher avec
6,26 g d'alcool dans le sang
on ne sait pas où elle en est
renault a la prétention d'apparaître
comme une entreprise normale c'est en
ces termes volontairement modeste que le
patron de la régie a commenté
aujourd'hui les résultats spectaculaires
du groupe 8,91 milliards de bénéfices un
exploit si l'on se souvient des années
noires quoi si lointaine un exploit due
à une politique musclée comme nous
l'expliquent jean pierre métivier
il y à un paradoxe au genou la régie 7
du terrain seuls trois voitures sur 10
vendus en france actuellement sont des
renault et malgré cela elle affiche un
bénéfice inégalée 8 milliards 9 en
redressement et sectionnelles si l'on
songe aux 12 milliards de pertes de 1984
même la filiale poids lourds véritable
boulet depuis des années des analyses un
bénéfice un milliard de francs
fabrication presqu'à la demande
réduction des stocks amputation d'un
quart des effectifs soit 30000 personnes
et surtout un marché automobile fabrique
explique cette remontée mais il faut
rester prudent parce que il est clair
que la compétition va s'intensifier
il est clair que nous avons des menaces
de débarquement de deux producteurs
extérieurs
il est clair que l'avs sur l'avenir il
faudra nous battre et qu'il faudra
continuer à améliorer notre productivité
et notre efficacité et notre qualité
du coup les suppressions d'emplois vont
continuer 7000 personnes encore cette
année
mais nouveauté une prime d'intéressement
si pour
100 du salaire annuel environ sera
distribué aux personnels autre
singularité renom reste le constructeur
le plus endetté du monde même si sa
dette est ramenée à 23 milliards de
francs
ainsi pour 1988 et du fait cette bête
renault ne paiera toujours pas d'impôts
et les syndicats réagissent bien sûr à
leur manière la cfdt réclame la
sauvegarde du salaire de l'emploi la cgt
plus d'investissements dans le social
perturbations cet après midi dans le
métro parisien à cause d'un mouvement de
grève de deux heures lancée par la cgt
le syndicat indépendant la situation
demain devrait être normal pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
profession les sages femmes étaient
appelés à faire grève aujourd'hui pour
obtenir une revalorisation de leur
statut et de leur salaire mais il l
était là quand même il est né presque
autant de bébés en france aujourd'hui
c'est ce que marie françoise riou a
constaté à l'hôpital
saint-vincent-de-paul à paris une
journée comme une autre à la maternité
de l'hôpital saint-vincent-de-paul et
très sage femme de service aujourd'hui
était tout grévistes et toutes
présentées toutes là pourquoi exactement
pour manifester que nous étions des
grévistes en étant l'un le faisant
savoir et pour par solidarité les unes
avec les autres
parce que c'est pas évident de faire la
grève c'est pas évident de de dire
pourquoi et de le faire admettre et par
la clientèle et parler
et gens avec qui on a l'habitude de
travailler d'autant que nous ne faisons
jamais la grève ou pratiquement pas les
sept bébés qui sont nés aujourd'hui n'y
ont vu que du feu
ils ont été mises au monde par les sages
femmes comme c'est le cas la plupart du
temps elle a surtout les accouchements
si l'accouchement se passe normalement
nous à peine en cas de problème
leur travail est absolument
indispensable à la bonne marche d'une
maternité donc leurs revendications sont
sûrement justifié j'adhère totalement
leurs mouvements actuellement je vais
accoucher ici à 48 heures par les
sages-femmes
bon ça s'est bien passé mais je crois
qu'elles ont un rôle important et de
lourdes responsabilités
les sages femmes arrêtent leur grève ce
soir elles attendent à présent les
propositions du ministère qui seront
connus jeudi leur mouvement a été suivi
à 55% à paris faible mobilisation en
revanche des personnels hospitaliers et
sociaux appelés à faire grève
aujourd'hui
les mouvements dans les milieux
hospitaliers se poursuivront toute la
semaine sur le front enseignants le
climat s'améliore entre les syndicats et
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
les propositions formulées hier par
lionel jospin ont été bien accueillies
par les deux principaux syndicats du
primaire et du secondaire
mais la base continue de renâcler
chantal qui merde
lionel jospin serait-il incompris
apparemment ces dernières mesures de
revalorisation n'ont pas satisfait tous
les enseignants 200 à 300 francs de plus
par mois à partir de 70 90 en 92 et
instituteurs recrutés avec une licence
gagneront mille francs de plus mais ils
perdront l'indemnité logement et
travailleront jusqu'à 60 ans 200 francs
pour chacun en 1981
in le relève le devenir des logements il
nous rajoute cinq ans je pense que nous
pouvons tous deux autres enfants parents
en fin de soirée tous ces enseignants
regroupés en coordination maintiennent
leur plateforme de revendications 2000
francs d'augmentation par mois
amélioration des conditions de travail
loi de programmation budgétaire pour
l'avenir dans cette profession
traditionnellement fidèles aux syndicats
de gauche
la coordination des enseignants fera
t-elle recettes
réponse la semaine prochaine après les
négociations finales avec le ministère
indiquait en tout cas plus à ce syndicat
qu'il fait qui ne fait pas son travail
qui est une véritable courroie de
transmission pas faire ils nous
empêchent même de lutter il nous empêche
de lutter le sni tant que syndic et je
demande à mes directions syndicales à ma
direction syndicale de ne pas signer un
contrat honte parce que dans les
collèges dans les lycées dans les écoles
nous savons que à la base nous ne sommes
pas d'accord
les syndicats ont donc une semaine pour
informer convaincre une base déçu
qu'elles soient syndiqués ou nous en a
planté des arbres aujourd'hui en france
une jolie idée pour fêter le printemps
est aussi le bicentenaire le président
de la république a donné l'exemple 5 go
dans la vienne c'est là at il rappelé
que le curé norbert 13 sacs a fait
planter le premier arbre de la liberté
en 1790 ont célébré l'installation de la
première municipalité
l'occasion pour le chef de l'état de
distiller quelques propos politique
laurent boursiers c'était une des
premières manifestations officielles
pour célébrer le bicentenaire de la
révolution française mitterrand a planté
lui-même un jeune chêne d'amérique au
milieu de la population du village
réunis près de l'église
le chef de l'état en a profité pour
parler d'écologie soulignons que l'homme
devait rester en accord avec son
environnement
françois mitterrand a aussi rappelé les
idéaux de la révolution au premier rang
desquels ils placent l'instruction
publique qui reste pour lui la priorité
des priorités
et c'est vrai que l'instruction publique
reste faible priorité des priorités
n'ont pas spécialement pour l'année qui
vient d'y voir les années précédentes vu
pour le temps qui commence c'est la
priorité de toutes les révolutions qui
se veut être au service de l'homme
chaque enfant chaque adolescent doit
pouvoir aller au bout de ses
possibilités de jouer toutes ses chances
et chaque adulte qui n'a pas pu
prolonger ses études doit disposer d'une
autre chance c'est pourquoi la nation a
consenti et doit consentir plus encore
les efforts considérables et d'abord
bien entendu un effort financier afin de
remplir cet objet rififi au centre même
si ce n'est pas dans son tempérament le
président du cds pire méhaignerie a
lancé un pavé dans la mare de
l'opposition hier soir à l'heure de
vérité
il s'est prononcé clairement contre nice
tunique udf rpr aux prochaines élections
européennes
véronique sainte olive pas d'ambiguïté
pas de tergiversation pierre méhaignerie
a livré hier sa vérité toute crue pour
lui foin d'union l'udf et le rpr doivent
affronter les élections européennes
chacun sous ses couleurs j'estime qu'il
faut donner la liberté de choix aux
électeurs
c'est ma première raison est tous les
sondages montrent avec deux listes
nous rassemblons mieux les électeurs
qu'avec unissent dans le reste de
l'opposition les réactions ne se sont
pas fait attendre
bernard pons lance la charge au nom du
rpr nous pensons que la meilleure
solution c'est véritablement une liste
d'union
les français ont besoin d'une
clarification et les élections
municipales viennent de montrer que là
où l'union n'existait pas nous obtenions
de très mauvais résultats
alors je pense que si on ne tire pas la
leçon des élections municipales est bien
c'est que véritablement on ne veut pas
voir les choses en face
le parti républicain est traversé de
courants contradictoires
françois léotard préconisait en janvier
une liste udf assortie d'un contrat de
confiance avec le rpr
en revanche ses amis gérard longuet et
alain madelin sont de farouches
partisans de l'union
j'ai une conviction très simple c'est
que l'europe ne doit pas être un enjeu
de politique intérieure
si l'on peut unir unir vraiment le plus
largement possible
l'opposition est bien au delà de
l'opposition autour d'un vrai projet
européen alors cette considération là
elle doit l'emporter sur toutes les
autres considérations politiques
intérieures le débat est engagé
pas de trêve pascale pour l'opposition
la corse et ce soir encore une île
bloquer les syndicats qui ont mal réagi
aux propositions de trappes de table
ronde du gouvernement les syndicats
s'apprêtent à manifester ensemble demain
pas de frictions en tout cas aujourd'hui
avec les forces de l'ordre lors de la
manifestation quotidienne à bastia
devant la préfecture
ces images viennent d'ailleurs de nous
parvenir isolement complet de lit
commencent à poser des problèmes
d'approvisionnement certains prudent
freineur précaution dans les magasins
d'alimentation situation inconfortable
aussi pour quelques deux mille personnes
bloqués en corse faute d'avion ou de
bateau nicolas jacques sauce jack up
nous raconte ajaccio depuis vendredi
dernier les barques de pêche nargue le
mont té fé lo elle l'empêchent de
larguer les amarres à moins
non on est avec personne au monde sauf
les passagers qui depuis cinq jours
attendent à bord du navire de pouvoir
rallier le et comment ça se passe le
premier soir normalement auraient été
ouvrier d'où le lendemain matin on nous
a donné le petit déjeuner depuis on est
logé un point c'est tout
donc on est obligé de descendre danger à
voir
ce nous occasionne évidemment devred
prévu et plus s'immobilise au contenu du
travail
ils sont 2000 sur l'île à attendre et à
chercher un moyen de transport à rêver
d'un avion taxi par exemple ils nous ont
proposé un voyage jusqu'à de propriano
alice à 1800 francs payés en liquide
sans assurance pour l'instant rien
n'indique que les bateaux de pêche
libérons le port ajaccio on semble
s'être fait à l'idée d'un blocus de
longue durée
aujourd'hui ils ont littéralement
dévalisé les grandes surfaces pâtes riz
viande huile sucre mais chacun se défend
de faire des stocks
vous avez acheté plus que d'habitude
prises en mars et prolongent tout le
jour
ça me l'ont dit ils vous êtes
anormalement changez de jambe je n'ai
pas peur j'ai l'habitude je le vends des
surprises en novembre que nous voyons se
verrait en temps de guerre au match
comme ça beaucoup d'huile
les dirigeants nationaux de la cfdt de
la cgt réclament chacun de leur côté des
négociations je vous rappelle que des
manifestations importantes doivent avoir
lieu en corse
demain 5 tonnes de lin dan mais aussi
plus d'une tonne et demie d'autres
insecticides particulièrement toxiques
ont été perdus quelque part dans la
manche
même si jusqu'ici les poissons n'en
n'ont pas souffert si les conteneurs
n'ont rien laissé filtrer c'est une
cargaison bien dangereuse que l'on
cherche à localiser
depuis jeudi dernier dominique tierces
aujourd'hui les chalutiers sont restés
au port motif interdiction par arrêté
préfectoral de pêcher mouillé ou draguer
les fonds sur près de 2000 kilomètres
carrés une mesure exceptionnelle pour ne
pas gêner les recherches effectuées pour
retrouver le voleur d'insecticides un
conteneur pour l'instant introuvable
même si bruxelles on l'annonçait sur
place qu'il y avait un espoir de
localisation le second navire chasseur
de mines
lorient qui est venue renforcer le
premier navire et qu' il ya des moyens
de détection twitter pour moi a repéré
un écho qui ressemblerait à celui d'un
conteneur donc ça pourrait être le
conteneur et qu'encore que nous soyons
sûrs donc il faut les identifier
dès demain ce chasseur de mines de la
marine nationale devraient mettre à
l'eau cet engin autopropulsés qui
explorera les fonds de la zone repérée
il est équipé d'une caméra vidéo qui
permettra de dire avec certitude s'il
s'agit du conteneur d'insecticides
difficulté majeure la profondeur des
eaux lorsque le remorqueur a perdu le
conteneur on ignore où il s'est posé
précisément deux hypothèses profondeur
70 mètres sur un sol sableux
au fond d'une fosse à moins 170 m et les
conditions de repêchage serait dans ce
cas très délicate à taire la polémique
va bon train
les pêcheurs s'est plaint de ne pas
avoir été prévenu de la situation ils
redoutent les conséquences économiques
de cette affaire j'ai une histoire que
le projet vous unissent pour le poisson
lequel alors que les consommateurs
sachent bien que le chalutage est
complètement impossible dans la zone
d'interdiction les écologistes quant à
eux souligne une fois de plus que cette
zone est à haut risque
la dimension exacte du danger c'est
difficile de l'évaluer
aujourd'hui mais ça pose un problème de
fond c'est la grande circulation sur ce
rail en manche c'est la circulation de
combustible irradié c'est là que
circulation de gaz toxique en fait tout
un tas de containers circulent ici
une cellule de crise a été mise en place
au ministère de la mer ici on veut jouer
la transparence
chaque jour les relevés de prélèvements
d'eau sont rendus publics
précisons qu aujourd'hui encore aucune
trace de pollution par le lin gran n'a
été enregistré ne pensez jobic touche à
sa fin le jugement a été mis en délibéré
aujourd'hui jusqu'au 28 avril après plus
de deux semaines de débats souvent
houleux
l'enjeu l'honneur et les méthodes d'un
commissaire et me roesch dernière
bousculade autour du commissaire jobic
visage serein apparemment sûr de lui le
même que celui qu'il a affichée pendant
20 jours
ses avocats ont plaidé les des biens sur
son innocence complète face à des
accusations il dit
né de la rumeur d'une rue la plus
sordide de paris mais ils n'ont pas tant
parler de l' affaire le procureur
s'était déjà chargé de la démonter à
l'audience d'hier ils ont parlé de
l'homme brisé physiquement et moralement
trop de mal a été fait de valence et
maître gilbert collard
s'il s'en sort comment s'en
remettra-t-il toutes les voix se sont
donc fait entendre trop souvent dans une
inimaginable cacophonie que chacun s'est
finalement plus à déplorer mais qui
restera le symbole d'un procès sous très
haute tension
le tribunal rendra son jugement dans un
mois mais on peut d'ores et déjà
s'interroger sur les conséquences de cet
affrontement d'une rare violence que
nous avons assisté entre un commissaire
un juge d'instruction est donc à travers
eux entre la police et la justice en
france après d'autres pays la justice
doit désormais se prononcer sur des
affaires douloureuses liés au sida
le premier cas à être jugé et celui
d'une dame de 62 ans séropositives par
hasard et par malchance après une
transfusion de sang
la compagnie d'assurance contre laquelle
elle s'était retourné refuse de payer la
provision qui lui est dû isabelle staes
comme si rien n'avait changé dans leur
petit pavillon nemours pierre emilienne
mène une vie paisible en apparence elle
est séropositive contaminés il ya quatre
ans lors d'une transfusion sanguine
après l'accident la route
le donneur est identifié un détenu de
fleury mérogis doxique oman est
homosexuel mais à l'époque le dépistage
des dons n'est pas systématique
il ne le sera qu'en dessous de 85 un
seul recours attaqué le chauffeur
responsable de l'accident
mais s'il n'y avait pas eu de d'accident
il n'y aurait pas eu d'accident par la
faute complète du type qui a grillé le
feu il y aurait pas eu de de
l'éclatement de la rate
je répond au besoin de tant de
transfusion le jour où on vous a dit que
vous étiez séropositives
comment vous avez réagi ce jour là à le
ciel nous tombait sur la tête
vraiment on s'est dit qu'on allait plus
voir personne de notre entourage qu'on
allait vivre tout seul tous les deux
c'était un effondrement du bloc par la
maladie et tout ce que je souhaite c'est
mon plus grand soin c'est le vôtre aussi
mena
ah oui et puis pourquoi avoir peut
grandir mes petits enfants emilia ne
voit plus son fils il lui a tourné le
dos en apprenant la nouvelle elle n'a
toujours rien touché de ces deux
millions de francs de dommages et
intérêts la sphère arrivera en mai
devant la cour d'appel de paris première
juridique lourde de conséquence aux
états unis la cour suprême a déclaré
constitutionnelles les tests de
dépistage d'alcool et de drogue sur
certains fonctionnaires responsables de
la sécurité du public notamment dans les
chemins de fer ou dans les douanes en
revanche à washington un juge fédéral a
suspendu pour au moins dix jours le
couvre feu que le conseil municipal de
la capitale américaine voulait imposer
aux jeunes dans l'espoir de réduire le
crime et la drogue
la situation devient intenable comme
nous le montre jacques à bouchain les
étrangers ignore ce washington l'a
submergé par le crime et la drogue
119 morts depuis le 1er janvier 46 de
plus qu'en mars 88 année rocha les
victimes sont essentiellement les noirs
des quartiers pauvres et sept meurtres
sur dix sont liées au trafic de
stupéfiants
la police submergé réclame des renforts
qu'on lui accorde pas faute de crédits
et le trafic surtout de la cocaïne
ces temps on parle de 300 points de
vente répertoriés entre les dealers
c'est la guerre pour le contrôle d'un
secteur d'où les cats ont longtemps à
différents le congrès s'inquiète on ne
peut pas laisser les gens de cette ville
se faire tuer comme dans une capitale du
tiers-monde dirigé par un despote
ce cri d'alarmé lancé par un sénateur
visait avant tout le maire de washington
marion de bari accusé d'être un
personnage incompétents et corrompus
sous la pression de son conseil
municipal le maire s'étaient ralliés du
bout des lèvres au projet de couvre-feu
pour les mineurs projets rejetés
provisoirement hier par un juge
si vous voulez faire des bêtises
le couvre-feu ne changera rien pour ces
jeunes noirs hallyday à la fois absurde
et inapplicable
même réaction hostile dans les écoles
des quartiers résidentiels comme le
lycée français respecté le couvre-feu
non non j'ai déjà moins de 18 ans objet
d'un pression avant minuit le week-end
c'est bon c'est pas dans nos habitudes à
sortir quand même et c'est pas la police
se faire le rôle du parrain
couvre-feu ou pas cette milice d'un
genre spécial fait beaucoup mieux que la
police dans la guerre antidrogue à
washington ses membres appartiennent à
la secte des musulmans noirs
réputé pour son fanatisme anti blanc et
son antisémitisme
depuis un an les musulmans ont chassé
les trafiquants de leur secteur un
nettoyage qui s'opère selon des méthodes
expéditives et violent la police a
d'abord ticket et la même procédé à
quelques arrestations
et puis elle a finit par composer en
reconnaissant que les miliciens
islamiques
obtenez des résultats indiscutables les
musulmans ne sont pas vraiment aimé il
suscite plus la crainte que la
popularité
pourtant on les réclame partout où sévit
la drogue avait des effectifs réduits
ils n'ont pourtant pas les moyens de
multiplier des patrouilles permanentes
en charriant trois casques bleus
irlandais de la finul la force des
nations unies tués ce matin par
l'explosion d'une mine au liban sud et
la partie chrétienne du liban est par
ailleurs isolé bombardés par l'armée
syrienne
une épreuve de plus pour la population
chrétienne le ministre syrien des
affaires étrangères est à paris
aujourd'hui il devrait être interrogé à
ce sujet par roland dublin en irlande en
irlande du nord l'armée républicaine
irlandaise revendique l'assassinât de
deux officiers de police un pompier
revendication par l'ira de l'assassinât
des deux officiers de police tué hier
près de la frontière avec l'irlande du
sud
les deux victimes ont été abattues au
cours d'une embuscade sur une route de
campagne
jamais depuis 1969 l'armée républicaine
irlandaise le set est attaqué des
officiers de police d'oran si élevé
voici les dernières images tournées par
kornel la groupe caméraman hollande est
un des trois journalistes tués dimanche
dernier au salvador
ici quand elle l'a goûts et des
confrères photographes sont pris dans un
échange de coups de feu entre l'armée et
la guérilla cornell la gros films il
filme jusqu'au cou pour le chemin de
l'hôpital le camion qui transporte la
gauche nettement baissé sera attaqué par
un hélicoptère de l'armée
les pays bas ont demandé des
explications au salvador
un boeing 707 s'écrase en fin d'après
midi près de sao paulo au brésil
selon un premier bilan officiel il y
aurait dix morts et 200 blessés
l'avion est tombé sur une favela un
bidonville où il a explosé
les acteurs sont américains le
réalisateur et britanniques son film
précédent s'intitulait sammy et rosie
s'envoient en l'air ce qui est nettement
moins élégant que les liaisons
dangereuses le chef-d'oeuvre de
choderlos de laclos mis cette fois au
goût anglo saxons nicole lecornu
langlois et alain ont rencontré la
marquise de merteuil alias dan klaus
favorite
tous les navires à 15 ans je possédais
déjà les talents auxquels la pelouse
compte partie de nos politiques doivent
leur réputation
il est surprenant dans les personnages
les 2 200 en soit toujours aussi vives
rouge controversé mêmes brito rencontre
insolite entre un roman épistolaire du
xviiie siècle est une star
hollywoodienne mais déjà des actrices
comme jeanne moreau au cinéma où
caroline cellier au théâtre avait été
séduite par ce chef-d'oeuvre de la
perversion amoureuse et maintenant glenn
close
madame de merteuil
m
adixen regrettable et je crois que l'un
des grands attraits de ses personnages
avaient aidé à voir cette magnifique
apparence si riche si puissante et si
contrôler c'est l'histoire d'une grande
passion
un mot love you go for edelman
mais sa fausseté
la monuc est de série
elle est aussi je crois une grande
romance jours c'est une belle histoire
d'amour qui font mal
une histoire machiavélique aussi devenu
grâce à stephen fry ce un film subtil
astucieux brillantissime accord les
liaisons dangereuses vie par jean paul
gaultier
le couturier qui a toutes les audaces
même celle de choisir des mannequins qui
ne sont plus des jeunes filles en fleur
il vient de dévoiler sa collection
d'hiver yauba grégoire et l1
mais non c'est pas agressif en attaque
où des filles est un spectacle qu'il
règle comme un chef d'orchestre et
charbon tout le monde doute y être c'est
le mas le défilé auquel on doit assister
jean paul gaultier on amland états mais
on vient
ne serait ce que pour le délire un côté
spectaculaire qui peut être mais qui
peut paraître provocateur et agressif
mais en vérité ce sont ces mêmes
vêtements que je présente d'une certaine
façon la fois après dans les boutiques
et ils sont portables puisqu'on les
forces
il est le deuxième dans le peloton des
créateurs qui vend le plus 500 millions
de chiffre d'affaires
les américains en parle comme d'un
phénomène dans le défilé une journaliste
un homme travesti sa cousine je suis dit
qu'en fin de compte y avait pas que le
type même qu'un l'archétype du mannequin
traditionnelle qui était bien mais aussi
d'autres formes de beauté j'essaye de
les montrer c'est en fin de compte je
crois que ce toucher à ces prêts en fin
de compte de ce qui se passe dans la rue
et c'est ce que je fais pour mes
vêtements soient apportées c'est la rue
qui m'intéresse c'est la vie on fait
quoi un vêtement dans un musée ou un
vêtement sur un simple c'est la mort
vaultier que ça pour rire mais pas du
tout il a sens de l'humour jeu aucun
sens de l'humour
quatre mille personnes sous la halle de
la villette on ne se précipite pas pour
rien ne s'amuse peut être pas mais nous
luis
j'ai aucun sens de l'humour je suis
quelqu'un c'est très ennuyeux
non je suis quelqu'un de très travaillé
pas facile à porter surtout à l'antenne
sophie davant façon beaucoup plus
classique va vous parler du temps demain
vers minuit henri sannier vous donnera
les dernières informations de la journée
rendez-vous demain matin comme tous les
jours des semaines à 6h45 avec roger
zabel et son équipe
invité de gérard morin à 7h45 un
professeur d'économie jacques marseille
qui vient de sortir un livre chez albin
michel qui s'intitule la france
travaille trop c'est nouveau voilà très
bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à demain 20
heures